you said you like didn't know much about
youtubers before you became one so what
made you like want to audition to become
one
in the first place well hmm let's see i
do think i mentioned this story briefly
before on stream
um but i had some other reaper mates um
who also were looking into the
the hololive thing and we're talking
about it um and i
just kind of i listened in and i was
like oh okay okay sounds interesting i'm
getting sick of swinging my scythe
around all the time
um and what's interesting though is that
um
i kind of i kind of did i kind of didn't
say anything when i auditioned to those
friends
i i didn't know i was just kind of i'll
just give it a shot because i didn't
think i was going to get in
i thought that they had way better
chances than me and so i was like well
okay i'll just do it let's do it for
for shits and giggles right just for fun
um and then
about midway through before we even
heard anything before things even got
moving
i got real guilty so i told my friends i
said hey listen look
i didn't uh i went ahead and i
auditioned for the thing um
that you guys did yes just so you know
i'm not trying to be slimy or anything
before things start popping off
right just letting you know what's up it
was awesome so you betrayed your friends
no no no it's not like animals
no wonder you have to drink to get the
sorrows
i mean you know the good news is they
were very happy for me yeah yeah
[Music]
i think it was genuine though i think
but i get what you mean i get what you
mean for sure
i mean yeah you're friends right you've
got to you must have known i was like
slight bit of like i'm so happy for you
i mean we still talk and we still cheer
for each other so i like to hope that
things are still cool with them
on your pile of money
[Applause]